i'm very much a middle ground
i'm looking at people like choosing what
they want to choose but i just think
we're not honest with women about the
consequences so like even with body
cameras
who cares because i don't care about the
consequences
and be like people like do you care if
your family yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
about my family
that's totally fine like i'm i'm all for
empowering women to do what i want to do
like if you if you want to go start your
only fans go ahead say i'm not going to
stop you
go crazy like get that bat but but
what i do think we do is like lie to
younger women and tell them there's no
consequences for that stuff
and and so we'll say like oh do sleep
with whoever you want and men won't care
they shouldn't care but they do care but
uh it depends if you think it's a lie it
really it's really like it's not it's
not it's not if i think it's a lie it's
like i have these
99 male followers i listen to men talk
every day they do care and biologically
there's a reason they care yeah i mean i
do do they care less than they did 100
years ago sure sure yeah yeah i don't
think like most guys want to but then
i think most guys don't want their [ __ ]
on only fans yeah but then we can talk
about okay like let's get real like
women couldn't vote women couldn't have
jobs black people were seen as literally
inhumane right and so you know if we
took that
that mindset back to where we were then
black people weren't human
and so you would not be sat here with us
because you would not yeah you would not
yet i'm just a little confused what is
that like i just was
i'm just confused what did that have to
do with what we were talking about so
it's in relation to saying like we're
lying okay so then essentially the
people who went black people are people
they were liars back then okay
i don't know but this is this is what
i'm saying it's it's lying to women when
we're saying like statistically they're
like for example when you when you sleep
with more men you lose your ability to
pair bond so you have a harder time
bonding with your husband later on like
the person that you marry and there
there's
a million studies that'll back this up
yeah yeah the people you sleep with the
less
like you you have a higher probability
of being divorced yeah yeah so so saying
to women empower yourself and sleep with
whoever you i'm not i'm not saying women
should be prudent not everyone wants to
get married and not everyone wants to be
parabonded and not everyone and not
everyone is scared
no and that's that's fine and so but i
think we should give women all of the
information okay so yeah so i'm saying
like if you don't want to be married and
you want to be like by yourself if
that's what you want to do go ahead go
go do it i'm don't but like don't i
think a lot of times girls follow this
advice and they're not they're not
giving all the information but yeah
we're also just assuming that every man
is going to be like
you're worthless oh i'm not i'm not
assuming every man but i think that like
majority okay
would you would you prefer a girl that
slept with a hundred people or slept
with ten especially for me ten yeah yeah
and like i think if you ask like yeah
guys would you prefer someone more pure
or more more of a hoe most guys are
gonna say more pure yeah but then you
see for a relationship yeah but then you
see who and what people then you see who
and what people watch on social media or
porn or who they engage with and you're
like oh you're a hot celebrity or
someone with a lot of followers or
someone who is very desirable or someone
who is and that's it nothing is black
and white the one thing i say about that
is i understand about that whole
desirable thing but guys don't really
care
how much
a girl is desired by other men that
seems to be more of a
woman thing that they'll use
pre-selectors by other women does that
make sense yeah so like you know
you said this example i'll be honest no
matter how many guys are looking and
thirsting over lizzo
i'm not going to be thirsting over her i
mean she's not what i would look for
where is like you get someone like jonah
hill if he was just your average guy no
one would want him but because of who he
is and women fawn over him a lot of them
see him as attractive because he's
desirable to other women does that make
sense
yeah like 100 like i'm that's it i'm
unfortunately i i'm i'm aware of the
reality i'm not like delusional um
but then i'm aware of the science but so
being that psychology has been my life
for the past like oh my god when i
started i started studying it
oh my god 12 years ago um and so it's
the understanding of why it's behavior
has come become that way and the
anthropology and all of that stuff
um so i come from more of a scientific
fact but then i'm like i obviously know
my bias i obviously know xyz but yeah
like i'm not gonna i'm not delusional in
the lizzo being a big woman is not
attractive but then you know like yeah
it's so so would you agree that we
should give like like the advice if for
a girl that wants to be married would be
to like sleep with as little men as
possible
if you want to get married to the
highest value guy you can
no i'm not saying like be a prude i'm
not saying no no no no yeah it's like
it's like you should want to marry a man
that wants you regardless but but you
don't think you don't think your choices
have consequences like no i think
there's a consequence right and so you
don't think we should be honest to the
next generation saying hey these are the
consequences for those actions if you if
you get on the internet and you you post
your naked body like a guy that that's
worth a date but one guy will care and
one guy
but but do the guys you want care is the
question that's i think that's different
i think the the difference is the the
high quality guys that most other women
would want
he's more he's going to care about these
things whereas there'll be some guys who
don't care but it's likely that those
guys that don't care not the guys you
want but then quality again is
subjective like would you rather have
someone who just accepts you for who you
are and loves you for who you are and
your history because then porn stars get
married but the numbers porn stars okay
but here's the thing they need to other
porn stars though
but but here's statistically actually
not correct because i get studied here's
here's the thing the numbers the numbers
don't lie and actions have consequences
yeah right and so we could say oh it's
subjective like what is quality but like
when you it's supply and demand yeah
like what what guys and why do we need
to all fit into the majority why do we
like i'm very happy being an anomaly i'm
very happy being oh oh like and i and i
say and i say go if you want to be an
anomaly go do it if that's what makes me
happy i'm never going to tell someone
how to live their life but what i'm
saying is like why do we lie to younger
women instead of giving them all the
information
like why don't we say the younger woman
if you if you want the highest the guy
with the most options okay if you want
the highest quality guy you can attain
putting your starting and only fans is
not the best way to get there but then
it's like i don't understand like to me
like this is common sense and i feel
like we should agree on this and it's
almost like you like are looking for
that exception because you don't want to
like
you don't want to because what we're
doing then is putting what he wants and
he desires and he values above ourselves
well because it's not always about you
and that's that's what i'm saying is
that he gets to choose who he wants to
marry and if you want to we get to
choose who we want to marry no women
marry who they can no i don't think
that's that's true like women
they have to propose so we don't choose
we don't have to no not at all
but do you not think do you not think
would you agree that women decide who
have sex
yeah yeah
so we do not think that it is men who
decide
who gets married
no because a woman can say no
or a woman can ask and a woman has the
ability to be like look if you're not
going to commit to me i'm going to walk
away no i know but men can also say no
to sex right but we understand that
culturally when it comes to having sex
it is women who decide get access
yeah but you women usually don't say no
to marriage either
the majority of women who are proposed
to accept
i don't yeah i don't know statistically
that or certain again it's because what
i mean is like you know you know that
when you stay from the first day of a
guy you know that he would have sex with
you straight away
so
nine times out of ten a guy is ready to
have sex before the woman that's why she
has the power to who has sex right
but also nine times out of ten it is the
woman who is ready for the commitment so
he decides who he commits to and i think
that's what pearl's saying saying that
when it comes to marriage
i think here's the thing like
before any woman has sex with a guy
she has he has to qualify himself to her
before she accepts that intimacy right
so the same is true
that women have to qualify themselves to
men if they want relationship and
commitment
but then so this then falls back to the
patriarchy why is it the women
are the ones who are like i have to look
good i have to be hairless well why do
the men have to say oh i have to have a
good job i have to like a girl could be
unemployed a dude will still date her
but like men have to qualify themselves
to women too it's like like you're
trying to like take away the things that
men care about yeah and the things that
like the things that women and men care
about just are yeah well that's that's
why i'm very i'm i'm so frustrating in
that i'm very gray area i'm very so
that's it i've had men that are broke
men that are
objects i'm gonna say objectively not
very good looking men that are short men
that actually bring little to the table
other than being nice right and um but
would you would you prefer a man that
like i would prefer yeah i would 100
prefer a man that brought me more
offered me more but it didn't stop me
from dating other men it didn't stop me
but then i think
i think i'm the anomaly in that but i'm
saying like you would still prefer the
man that had more just like the man
would still prefer the woman that had
had less guys yeah and i think like like
it just is i'm not saying i mean i mean
it's not like you know
like double standards just are yeah yeah
i was gonna say as well do you not um
i think the difference is
that and this goes back to like what you
were saying earlier what we've all said
earlier is i understand the notion of
you know you said oh but you should want
someone who loves you for you
but we all acknowledged earlier earlier
that love isn't condition is not
unconditional like love is very or if we
say love at least who we choose is
definitely conditional and some like you
could meet a guy who you think oh he
rocks my world intimacy wise but if you
want to start having a family and he's
really not doing anything with his life
it's like you may really care about him
but you may not choose him over the next
guy who can do that for you does that
make sense yeah and then i think it also
depends upon like i'm gonna be real it
really depends upon your mental health
your well-being you're like so i settled
for people who treat me like [ __ ]
and if if someone outside when amy this
is what this guy is doing to me i'd be
like are you confused like leave him
like what the [ __ ]
um
and yeah like i fully like agree with
that i fully agree that like that's it's
just not a simple yes or no but would
you would you would you then go back
because love is conditional would you go
back on your statement that like the man
shouldn't love you for you like it's
it's conditional based on the choices
you yeah like that's it so yeah that
makes sense so so you would agree then
to younger women we should tell you them
that actions have consequences and going
on only fans might not be the best
action if you want a husband i think
well that's the reality is that yeah it
will it will have consequences yeah
because it will some men won't care some
men will care you have to be okay and
you have to be responsible to be like i
know that if i'm one only fans some men
are going to be like you're trash well
and as long as you're okay with that
then and especially the men you want
just like like women that are models who
do they tend to date
oh hot models yeah yeah no no like like
rich men yeah rich men
men with the option i mean look at i'm
not saying like all guys that's like the
halo effect as well like if you are good
looking you are deemed to be more worthy
well then like a bad looking person no
it's more for women like men it's more
their accomplishments like us we have a
lot more value in our looks
which we all we enjoy the benefits of
but that's well wow oh and this is such
an anti like feminist thing but
i will sometimes i will i'm
i'm a feminist but in this world i'm
like if i can bat my eyelashes and do
the whole little cute little ah i'm like
no i will fully milk yeah i'm gonna try
for sure i will do it and people are
like but you're a feminist and you
shouldn't do that and i'm like look if i
need to get ahead in any way i can if i
need to be better looking yeah to come
across as better i'm going to be real
well if i came here looking like trash i
think that i'd get a lot like more mean
or yeah
like i'm gonna i'm gonna be real um
yeah like no i totally like well i think
i think it's like we so it's almost like
like feminism they want equality when it
it they almost only wanna gray no no i'm
saying like we don't actually want
equality it's just equality when it
benefits us yeah so so here's the thing
because i think you're right
if you're going to call a spade a spade
you you as a woman you're going to use
the advantages you have
of being a woman to get yourself ahead
right that's what you just said
yeah
so
yeah
so then
can we i'm just playing devil's advocate
here can we then get annoyed at men
who use the advantages that they have to
get ahead
yeah but oh that's it it's it's not all
like it depends on the situation the
circumstance i'm so frustrating that i'm
very much like every situation
you can't block i think it's just when
you have to answer a question that goes
against your belief system that's what
that is no but that's no so because i
did dbt i'm non-judgmental and i'm very
much non
you don't commit you sit on the fence
because nothing is black and white
nothing and it makes life a lot more
enjoyable to not be so committed to a
certain belief or a certain way of
thinking i'm very open-minded i'm very
yeah i'm very happy to be told
i'm very happy for someone to have a
different opinion and to argue it and
i'm very much like oh do you know what
i've changed so i used to be very yeah
anti-abortion this is what really
surprises people i was very
anti-abortion as a teenager right and
then i switched and i was very i was
actually i was a massive prude i was a
massive prude i was very judgmental on
girls who were promiscuous or xyz
and now i'm like the opposite
and i'm very open to it it's not really
like it's not really like judgmental i i
don't
i don't care what people do like i don't
i don't think who you sleep with says
who you are as a person like i don't
know i don't give it like you want to do
that but i just what what i don't like
is acting like there's no consequences
for it no there are and there is i'm
telling young girls there's no
consequences because there are and that
would literally be a
a blank face lie because we know they're
right we know they're all right and in
an ideal world
yeah there wouldn't be but you've got to
be you got to be a realist you've got to
be a realist and be like there are
consequences to certain men and if those
are the men that you're after then you
have to actually cater to what they want
right and right so yeah yeah yeah so we
agree yeah yeah in a realist way yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no
yeah like next question yeah no no but
like nobody is in a realist way like and
it's not something that i
am happy about or i want to accept it
because of who i am as a person i'm like
oh okay if a guy is like that's it your
body count matters or xyz matters then
i'd be like okay compatibility wise
you're not for me and they always say
you know if you wanted to he would or to
one person this will matter but to
another person this won't matter but
being realistic being that's it being
the reality of how life is how the world
is how society is how
[ __ ] matters [ __ ] has consequences and
you just have to be okay with
being comfortable with the controversy
yeah i i agree with that yeah
so as long as women and i do think it's
a lot more on women i really do so long
as a woman is self-assured enough and
her self-worth is to be like so i've had
men say to me and be like
um
i've had men be like oh you're not
you're not like
thick enough you're not xyz or um i get
told that i'm dramatic or that i'm too
opinionated or although i get told i'm
too much quite a lot
and it really impacts who i am as a
person but then all of my boyfriends so
i asked a bunch of them recently i was
like was i difficult to love and they
went no you're very easy to love
and they were like maybe difficult to be
with the times but i get a lot of guys
be like you're difficult you're too much
you talk too much you and i'm like what
i'm hearing is that i'm abundant and you
can't handle me and i'm like i don't
want to do this is it possible because i
get that too i'm a chit chatter i love
to talk but it's just like it is too
much sometimes who cares you're not too
much they're not enough no i think
sometimes it's too much but it's okay
like i'm not perfect as long as you as
long as you're that's but that's it as
long as we can be like i'd be talking
you know as long as we can as long as we
can be like okay cool
cool like like i'm not going to change
then that's like the whole we know
there's consequences but i don't think
it like like it's kind of a bad
mentality to say like oh like i'm i'm
enough like i'll never change like
sometimes you're not sometimes
for other people you've got to have that
middle ground between being selfish or
confident and then being humble
and then ah that's it you you want to be
palatable and accepted but you also want
to be
confident and secure and i don't care if
other people accept me or not and it's
uh it's messy